faire une Cendrillon qui va faire 2,50
de haut cette année au Rivau voilà donc
avec des pâtissons
et des béybou château des fé le château
du Rivau se devait de célébrer la
citrouille le jardin potager en émerge
de toutes sortes dans l'esprit du lieu
je crois que la citrouille est associée
au compte de fée grâce à Cendrillon
Cendrillon qui a perdu son carrosse qui
s'était transformé en citrouille géante
et de là ça a marqué l'imaginaire à ité
courge cucurbitassé et autres
citrouilles sont cueillies pour démarrer
une seconde vie je vous apporte une
Sucrine du Berry la plus onctueuse des
citrouilles pour que vous puissiez en
faire une délicieuse soupe voilà si la
citrouille peut-être gravée sculptée
transformé en lanterne ou en décoration
ici elle finit dans la
cuisine le plus difficile en fait c'est
ça vaêre d'éplucher et despépiner le et
de trancher le la sucrine mais sinon
pour le reste c'est facile
oui la sucrine en fait est très est très
bonne parce qu'elle est elle a un petit
goût de marron et de
châigne le circuit est plutôt court
puisque les citrouilles cultivées au
château finissent en soupe au restaurant
du Château on a trois types de
citrouilles avec vraiment des qualités
gustative très très différent on a
d'abord la sucrine nuberry qui est
peut-être la plus subtile avec une
texture un peu moins onctueuse que les
autres mais qui a vraiment un goût assez
unique et qui est caractéristique de la
région dans notre potager on a plus de
50 variétés de courg et de citrouille
donc le promeneur peut se demander mais
à quoi ça sert d'avoir autant de
variétés de citrouille et donc on lui
fait goûter ses différentes soupes ou
bien confitur pour voir les différentes
caractéristiques de chaque citrouille et
qu'il puisse comprendre à quel point
c'est important de préserver toutes ces
citrouilles et d'avoir beaucoup de
variétés ce weekend pour la fête de la
citrouille ce cucurbitassé sera le roi
de la fête jusque dans les assiettes